danke danke danke
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft hier um meine
stimme ist immer noch ein bisschen in
dem eimer drin es sind schon zwei leute
auf dem server das sehr interessant
westländer drauf ich ständer drauf
gespielt und debitor lp hallo hallo
guten tag
devito bekommt vom guten tag
ja wir spielen hier mit shader auf dem
papier drucken ein bisschen ganze werden
muss natürlich erst mal auf body mit
shader wir spielen hier mit shader auf
dem hero server das ist gerade shader
nummer eins und ihr seht es läuft
komplett flüssig es ist echt so
unglaublich wie flüssiges läuft ist weiß
ich ich liebe das eben wie es läuft ich
kann jetzt blöcke abbauen
platz und jetzt stehen da wieder hin
moment war ich denn da mit stella wieder
und weiß ich es läuft als überflüssig
das ist shader 1 also irgendwie der
umfrage ist zwei wurden fast nie gewählt
aber schade 1 nummer drei das ist nummer
drei und die meisten meinten nummer eins
allerdings mal noch sehr viele nummer
drei deswegen ihr findet jetzt noch mal
was ihr findet es findet jetzt noch mal
die möglichkeit statt dass ihr nochmal
abstimmt und zwar nur zwischen 1 und 3
und da war ungefähr das gleiche ich
glaube es waren irgendwie 400 stimmen
für 1 und dem 450 oder 350 für 3
deswegen weiß ich gar nicht
welche nicht annehmen sollte ich spiele
jetzt erst mal folgende nummer eins und
jetzt sagen schreibt nochmal einzelnen
nummer drei habt ja gerade auch immer
nummer 3 gesehen
deswegen schreibt das jetzt einfach in
die kommentare schreibt jetzt einfach in
die kommen übrigens am falsch gewesen da
ich ja hier das schmeiße ich musste es
aber bei mir in denen doch nicht kommt
auch schon zwei drin weiß ich nicht so
ich habe gehört dass es soll das bei mir
rein packe ich weiß dass es richtig war
ich habe hef gewählt also seht ihr auf
meinem zettel und mir deswegen ich
brauche erstmal häusern hier ein
bisschen weiter beziehungsweise ich weiß
gar nicht was ich machen möchte ich
möchte eigentlich jetzt endlich mal so
ein armes land machen
ich habe jetzt auch endlich mal mein
ding hier verändert meine meint mein
windows heiser dass sich jetzt das nicht
immer so blöd gestreckt haben möchte ich
den hier haben stones lab und ihren sohn
dann muss ich auch erstmal eine ganze
kisten hier sortieren also wir sind hier
geschrieben stand dass der ist
bescheuert sind eigentlich überall diese
teile sind da auch ja und hier
da auch das feld müsse auch noch besser
machen also weiß ich ihr müssen wir
selbst schreiben wie es besser haben
wollt packt jetzt mal auf 40 ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt besser ist weil sich
ihr müsst mir selbst schreiben ob wir es
haben wollt also für mich ist es relativ
egal wie gesagt es ist halt komplett
eure euch überlassen er das ganze hier
wie dort könnt ihr für einen euro mega
trocken sind dass du dann einfach nur
weh hatte ich gerade tue weh so also
nein nein nein ihre kisten idee kommt
wieder zurück so und zwar kommt ihr
dahin dahin dahinter in dahin wenn ich
in meinem ersten woche werde ich mir auf
jeden fall noch im weg nach unten machen
die ich hier auch jetzt kommen die
ganzen dinge da wieder
soweit man da so ich weiß gar nicht wie
ich meinen weg nach unten bauen soll das
ding ja stimmt mich auch ein bisschen
bisschen gehabt ich wollte auf jeden
fall schockieren packen ich weiß nicht
ich damit zog ihn nach draußen kommen
soll
ich könnte ja da so eine tür nach
draußen machen aber
es hat gar nicht wichtig ob da rein
kriegen soll nicht glaub ich mache ja
noch sein stall
obwohl wie soll ich denn den steirer
erst mal hinkriegen sc nahen osten soll
jetzt mal hier ein bisschen sortieren
sortieren hier war mal reich das reicht
das reicht das recht das moment moment
sieben wenn ich das doch ein paar
gesehen
ja es muss reichen aber ich brauche
mehrere von daher reichte es nicht
ich brauche meine kumpels torjubels tun
kobil zudem stone town regie nicole
bild.de
so ein star wir haben ja hier nicht
sowas video you gotta wo wir einfach
alles mögliche raus machen können da
haben wir natürlich nicht so fünf davon
ab diese flöten wir fluten jetzt
danke danke danke wunderschön
wunderschön gefühlt ich immer wieder
nach sondern doofen weapons dann brauch
ich glaube ich auch noch ich gebe
einfach nur stand hier in den chat hier
und ein stent büring stanley hat mal was
ist denn das was mir gleich mal an mich
jetzt erst mal dass sie ganz kurz klappt
mit dem ja genau ich da sechs das gut so
12 11 ich habe jetzt mal drei ich hoffe
nur das reicht so drei stück habe ich
sowohl studentin
ich habe schon gedacht mit die auch so
cool hier vorzustellen weil ich könnte
theoretisch hier kann ich nichts am
nicht ab so dass es gleich auf der höhe
okay gut wo kann ich jetzt hinstellen
hierhin könnte ich durch einstellen
ja wir schlecht ein hin und da stelle
ich nur bis zu hin ist es denn überhaupt
noch mein grundstück
ich weiß gar nicht ob mein grundstück
ist ich meine wir haben eh keine genauen
grundstücks abgrenzungen
aber es ist wirklich nicht richtig mein
grundstück eigentlich witzig da wohl
irgendwer was klar ich weiß es gar nicht
haben wir so alles hier haben wir
eigentlich aber ich weiß nicht ich fand
den platz halt eigentlich ganz cool so
für meine rüstung oder ich brauche mir
hier einfach noch so hin dass man dass
man so weiß das ja noch mein grundstück
ist dann mache ich das einfach so dass
man so sieht so hey das kann auch noch
für den auch mal da geht das ja aus nur
um den das sieht man da aber nicht da
geht das ja wenn ich außen rum
ja man sollte eigentlich erkennen das
ist übrigens ich find das haus sieht mit
dem shader so unfassbar geil aus ich
finde es allgemein richtig cool
können wir wieder ein bisschen mops
klatschen gehen hierbei kfd ich weiß
auch gar nicht ob das uns erlaubt ist
dass wir die boxen gehen dürfen
ich weiß dass gar nicht was ist wenn ich
an stelle ruhig dafür endlich gar nicht
hoffen keine schalter betätigen das tut
es mir leid so ich denke zwar dass kev
nichts dagegen hat aber ich möchte mich
mit keinem verscherzen übrigen auch
richtig viele takte uhr sei nicht
exportiert was nicht das k4 einkommen
dann nicht das café reinkommt dann sind
ganz viele monster warte ich höre dir
einfach mal hin
sterbt gibt schweer herzen
nein ich will nicht dass auch mahnen
ich will dich das wef kommt das dann
richtig viele zombies sind die malberg
jetzt ich gehe hier nach dann einfach da
müssten die er glaube ich theoretisch
ein vbs pommes trocken wieder lachen
emmerick peace dingsbums 17 17
ja ich habe einfach 6 uhr dich einfach
die meisten von allen hier so ich
sortiere hier immer noch ein bisschen
ich brauche hier warten ehe das sind
alles so pocht darauf dass alles zu
sortieren wird immer meine rüstung jetzt
hier raus nehmen macht man kann ich erst
mal raus ziehen so ich weiß jetzt gerade
nicht so richtig wie das funktioniert
kann ich einfach okay gut funktioniert
doch so wie ich gedacht habe dann kommt
hier die diamonds ist bleibt dran
ja ich denke ich auch richtig viele
davon
dann der die rote hose der rummel
er kommt hier drin und die stiefel
kommen auch daran und die iron chef
playtech kann die kann ich endlich
möglich
ach so die solcher kev geben die solcher
kräfte daran tun die jetzt einfach mal
cakmak es in die kommentare das ich denn
da was dran getan habe da strom egal ob
jahr beenden aber nur dass ich in der
westkap und den helm noch kommen die
beiden helme dahin dass jetzt die kag
rüstung und das ist die coole rüstung
der sack war findet ihr unsere ganze
kraft darauf und dann werde ich mir ja
auch bald die dings machen die scale am
ort und hier soll ein schoko irgendwo
seinen schoko stand müssen wir von außen
heben gucken als denke den drittnamen
ausständig packt ihn jetzt erst mal
hierhin er tut ja kein wasser so rappen
oder meppen dingsbums wurde ich dann
noch nach unten
kyle moore heißt ist den kann ich ihr
nicht irgendwie mal eben finde ich den
ich irgendwie hier so auf die schnelle
da müsste der theoretisch irgendwo bei
seien hierbei den ganzen waffen übrigens
frederik blabla wurde ich auch noch was
draus machen
aus diesen krisen krams so dass auch nix
mammut kopf alter das wäre so geil
gemacht werden solche regale eine
glasglocke bottle alter darauf hätte
aber richtig bock drauf jungle world
posten achter können nur postens rein
alter habe ich glaube ich würde einfach
so gläser reinpacken so kommt es bei a
wie geil das aussieht oha mit dem shader
und der night session cookies brauche
aber ich denke da schrie la marra darf
lila über den kopf zieht das geil aus
ich hab mich doch bitte wie sieht das
mit diesem anderen felder aus damit
sieht das ein bisschen realistischer aus
aber auf jeden fall nicht so geil heftig
in den farben also ihr müsst mir
schreiben ob ihr denn hier lieber wollt
oder den hier der ist natürlich ein
bisschen farbenfroh müsst ihr wir
schreiben ihr könnt immer noch in die
kommentare schreiben
ich möchte auch eigentlich nicht so
lange aufnehmen wie es gehen wieso
50.000 jahre aber geht natürlich so
wartet ich brauche ich hier in dottel
ich glaube dir geh doch einfach so oder
oder kriegt man sogar direkt 3
jetzt mache ich mir mal hier so einfach
wie blöd ich bin so
die geil ich mache mir so ein tag
ich mache mir davon richtig richtig viel
aber ich brauche mehr so rasant so ist
dann hab ich jetzt genug
ich brauch karen stone wehrmacht mit
einer so viel lieber treibt immer direkt
so egmr lps sind übrigens doch für was
zu haben und zwar kann man dir zu dings
machen zu diesem level denksport sachen
der stadt erscheinen so ein bisschen
feiner den ich mir damit mein bogen muss
ich auch nochmal jemand auf wertach ich
hab doch diesen goldenen boden oder
andere ja ich glaub ich hab den verloren
als ich auf dieser tour da oder ich weiß
es ehrlich ich packe ich mal daran die
ich hoffe in dem ich mir die goldene
feder brauche ich auch die axt
eigentlich hatte ich die auch immer
vertauscht so dann packe ich jetzt noch
ein paar unnötige sachen die brauche ich
immer noch für einen hausbau doppelt so
viel wie es geht
so kupec beck ich weiß immer noch nicht
ob ich die da irgendwie noch anpacken
kann oder keine ahnung
die brauche ich auch immer noch reisen
brauche ich erstmal nicht mehr essen
braucht man immer mal gebrauchen so dann
nehme ich das glas immer gleich ganz
kurz draußen tausch gegen reisen werde
ich dann eben das eine reisen bekomme
zehn kids noch unnötig chocobo federn
auch unnötig zu coupé der auch weil ich
hab den ja schon genannt die murger
place könnte ich theoretisch schon mal
pflanzen so dann könnte sich das glas
wein daraus mache ich mir jetzt leben
die und daraus das nicht dass es an dem
ich bin blöd ich beim breit so ganz
viele regale möchte ich davon
ich habe richtig bock auf diese regal
ich finde richtig geil auch wenn er nach
halo porsches drin stehen wir sehen
einfach so als motiv
links allzu viele die sich richtig gut
aus freue ich mich richtig drüber
wer assets kurz was dann setzt also ein
paar merge mitteilen damit wir mal genug
geld haben und wir sind spiele bei 13
minuten und ich bin auch immer noch
irgendwie bisschen unscharf in der fels
camp ich weiß nicht woran es wirklich
kann auch nichts ändern
es ist irgendwie wie verhext so hier
kommen ein bisschen pötsch votings hin
die zombie dasein ein wald da hat mach
ich mir jetzt in deutschland bald
schön wirken noch genug sonne darf
natürlich auch das wichtigste auch die
bauern jetzt ein bisschen mehr von
dieser kacke hier toll jetzt habe ich
neun stück für einen baum verbracht
klasse super beste ja keine ahnung wie
macht ihr den eingang so als
hintereingang hatte ihr fotobuch
fehlbaum die mache ich da den eingang
management menschen das mache das jetzt
noch eine spezielle spaziert mache ich
das ich will da auf jeden fall
irgendwann chocobo stahl reinkriegen
oder soll ich den emi dazwischen ich
wollte ihnen dazwischen kleistern stimmt
aber da muss ich ja dauernd auch im raum
machen
warte mal wie ging da denn ihr da war
hier auch dann geht das in die
wahlkabine ryanair ist das doof kann ich
doch kein recht ihn auch man da
vielleicht da sind dann dadurch aber das
irgendwie zu englisch schachtel dann
wieder alles will ich diesen raum auch
gerne nach da noch ein bisschen noch
offen offen halten
aber ich will das jetzt auch nicht alles
wieder abreißen müsst ihr und habe ich
als ebene idee ihn seine erleuchtung
eigentlich auch nicht ich könnte ja mal
kerl ist viasit auf zuruf aus man nur
will hat nicht alles kaputtmachen im
spital
man es ruckelt immer noch so
zwischendrin ein bisschen mit den
schildern
ach ja toki keine ahnung wo richtig
parken soll parkinson höher
theoretisch geht ja auch auf dem dach
oder hey auf dem dach wird gehen da
macht eine wendeltreppe nach außen
einfach so mit dauern mit mit staunen
staunen staunen staunen oder mit mama
mit staunen besser erreichen acht schon
ich weiß es noch nicht
14 sollten eigentlich auf jeden fall
reichen machen das jetzt rum wo sollte
denn aufs dach können eigentlich so
dazwischen inzwischen so eine treppe
irgendwie nach oben kann man eigentlich
machen aber das ist dann das kollidiert
dann hiermit wieder so ein bisschen da
wird dann sogar das eigentlich besser
passen
passt das sogar boas liest sogar es
dürfte sogar perfekt passen dann habe
ich noch mehr wer davon per paypal
das sollte reichen
und zwar nicht nur auf dieser seite
jockey die man ganz kurzen steht noch da
nach da genau so so du bist natürlich so
fett dann bist einfach so völlig
bisschen dass wir das natürlich schon
ein verdammt dass ihr das hier natürlich
zwei breit machen müssen
also ich fand das cool hier ist zwar ein
bisschen eng an hier mal zum parken aber
wenn man vernünftig sein führerschein
besaß ich habe dann müssen wir das
endlich schaffen
oder soll ich dass sie komplett einfach
hoch laufen lassen oder ne das ist
eigentlich weder übertrieben da mache
ich mir dann einfach so eine coole
leiter hin
aber am besten wäre es eigentlich wenn
ich da warte ich noch mal kurz
ich gehe einfach gut komme ich geburt
ein und es kommt nur das okay label ok
ich weiß wenn ich wie das dann aussieht
mit dem label ist das eventuell
korrigieren das ist also ich schaue erst
mal ganz kurz wie das aussieht es
verbraucht eine menge rohstoffe vom
label cool klasse perfekt dass genau das
war warfare pack nicht gibt's nicht
wieso platten die man ihm die an den
rand machen kann dass man da irgendwie
so wie wir was man denn die bimmelt und
irgendwie weise nicht da wo man halt
damals die was mit mit burt white case
bla bla ist es überhaupt deutsche
casemod table des main kommt was es ja
so für sachen gibt wie geil damit muss
ich mich mal überall beschäftigen
ich hab es mir bisher nur diese kappe da
gemacht möchte auch zwei davon kann ich
eigentlich zum hatte jetzt mache ich
hier wieder killer luca action ja so
dass nämlich drin das ist bird schmidt
ich habe jetzt gar nicht mehr als ob
nicht warum nicht ich habe kein break
mehr
die mit birdrace directly die folge es
auch gleich wieder zählen aber ich
möchte noch zwei von diesen regierungen
machen dass man doch diese folgen doch
stand vorbei so soll der weg gegeben da
333 333 so das heißt ich brauche jetzt
das jahr ab und das hier dann kommt da
dass das höhe
das extrem bei slam oder muss ich dafür
erst mal wieder hier bis zum paradies
das hab ich nich papier irgendwo bin
schon ihr darunter die hab ich gar nicht
muss ich mal an pflanzen hier irgendwie
so papier hält sie zu spät
ich brauch leder bisschen das leder
clever in hallstatt [ __ ] genannt
bücher bücher bücher
ach nee nee nee nee nee nee nee
eigentlich mag ich muss eigentlich schon
längst aufhören
ich hätte auch gleich auf kommt mal
sieht das geil aus ich könnte jetzt auch
direkt zum dingsda reinstellen aber egal
ich mach's umständlich ja nee also in
meinem haus nimmt langsam form an also
ich find es hat sich wieder so ein
bisschen verändert hier so ganz klein
bisschen es hat sich halt immer ein
bisschen jackie mache ich jetzt noch
einen schöneren parkplatz ionen das hier
habe ich gebaut habe ich nicht gemacht
habe eine wahlergebnisse wieder
verändert und mir am ostends gemacht und
dann würde ich sagen nächste folge okuma
tokio hamann sie zu sein schatten
wie viele und wie ich sagen nächste
folgen werde ich mich darum kümmern dass
ich eventuell damit dem anlass auch
aufnehmen und dann hier das feld noch
ein bisschen schöner machen und mich
dann auch mal irgendwann endlich im live
stream um die essens vergabe kümmere
natürlich sagen es euch gefallen hat
will ich mich definitiv für beide
bewertungen freuen jetzt immer hier zum
ende wieder ach verdammt darauf jetzt so
laufen wie der schöne blick aufs haus
wie es sich verändert hat
denn wie ich sagen sie uns zunächst mal
wieder rein ciao